first of the two joint speakers loves
reading so much she's a member of four
book clubs
how you keep up with that let's find out
our other speaker loves The Flintstones
and her favorite character is Betty
Rubble
so everyone please welcome Danielle and
Celine to the stage
[Music]
my name is Danielle Laurice and I will
be presenting with my colleague Celine
stromgren
the title of our presentation is finding
Waldo our supported transformation of
unwieldy data into information
we work at the U.S Food and Drug
Administration FDA office of Regulatory
Affairs and I also wanted to say that
Selen and I are both chemists so we have
scientific backgrounds and definitely
not data science but here we go my
second disclaimer um is that everything
we present represents the views of the
speakers and should not be construed to
represent fda's views or policies
the office of Regulatory Affairs or Ora
is the second largest group by the
number of full-time employees within the
FDA as we can see from the left chair
only the center for drugs is bigger
I think there's feedback is your mic on
perfect
um
right the middle chart here shows the
breakdown of Ora staff into infectional
investigational and scientific and Labs
the split is about 80 inspectional and
20 labs
we think of Ora as the place in FDA
where the rubber hits the road because
the office is comprised of people who
are out traveling to firms doing
inspections Gathering samples and
analyzing those samples in this
presentation we're going to focus on the
laboratory and scientific network of Ora
which has roughly 900 staff and which
includes 12 Laboratory locations around
the contiguous United States Plus Puerto
Rico so this is who we're talking about
these regulatory labs and their
scientific Enterprise
so I'm happy to report that there is r
in FDA in fact there are two r's in Food
and Drug Administration when you spell
it out
anyway our studio is available to all of
FDA staff because it's an excellent tool
that allows sophisticated data trending
analysis organization visualization and
automation of workflows such as our
shiny interfaces
but we found that R could be popular
um even for those not previously trained
in programming due to its open excess
structure ease of use via availability
of packages the availability of the
online community support
and the existence of specific use groups
and communities even at the agency to
Foster collaboration across use of
applications and Joint troubleshooting
but there's a shift in the professional
landscape at the agency with an emphasis
on hiring and multi-disciplinary areas
so titles like chemist microbiologists
and engineer are kind of becoming things
of the past and getting replaced by data
scientists pharmaceutical engineers and
artificial intelligence architects
there's also a new community launched by
the fda's office of digital
transformation called Data forward that
uses r as a platform to trade a pilot
cohort in data science techniques
so how do data science and R mesh with
Ora
Ora scope intersects with all FDA
regulated centers and regulated products
which means that Ora Labs work with all
these product types listed
since these product types are so diverse
we get this two statistics at the bottom
the FDA regulated products account for
about 20 cents of every dollar spent by
U.S consumers and account for about 2.7
trillion dollars in annual consumption
so this helps convey the vast swath of
consumer products that Ora interacts
with but we also want to be clear that
Ora does not write or develop any
policies or regulations our mission
takes place post-market that is after
products are being marketed to the
public
so this sounds like an awful lot of work
but let's think about what data it
generates since we're here to talk about
data science
so rra has a vast amount of data that
relates directly to the agency's public
health Mission and there's a bunch of
examples such as facility inspection
reports enforcement activities outbreak
and Adverse Events and the reports
thereof laboratory results sample
Collections and it goes on
in addition to this data that's directly
generated from our Public Health Mission
Ora has operational data such as
training records or internal proficiency
records and Regulatory lab sample
turnaround times
but like many fine people before us we
find ourselves with all this data but
with issues as well
so most of our data is available but not
accessible in the way that we would want
it to be
so most data especially the type of data
that's acquired over time and under
changing parameters exists in a format
that does not lend itself to easy
extraction of key information and Trends
and further human brains are not wired
to reliably build cumulative
understanding of a data set acquired
over time the last data point gets the
most attention if there's a need to make
a particular decision at a given time
and this issue leads to the impulse to
reacquire new data rather than
leveraging the existing data that you
have
so sometimes it'll feel easier to
reacquire new data to address a specific
need rather than to distill
the existing data in an effective way to
get more robust and historical
information but the point here is that
reacquiring is in most case not the best
option and often for government agencies
this can manifest as Contracting and
hiring third-party contractors to do
this work for us
so further a Reliance on outside
expertise of contractors
um extends from the activation barrier
of not having a data proficient
Workforce
So within the agency there's an urgent
need to become proficient in tools such
as our which could in turn help us
deploy these data science techniques to
master our existing data and a data
driven approach could transform the
historical practice of policy making
based on anecdotal and qualitative
information into a much more robust
approach where objective and wholesome
evaluations can illuminate the right
actions and decisions so I'm going to
turn over to Flynn to discuss some case
studies that we've done
thank you Danielle
okay
now we would like to illustrate
um a use case for system for a
systematic data science approach
our example involves data in the form of
laboratory exercises acquired over
each exercise is basically an
application of a scientific method by
each laboratory in our Network to detect
unknown analytes in samples that
represent FDA regulated products so this
could be pesticides in fresh produce for
instance these exercises show that the
labs are able to run scientific methods
proficiently to obtain accurate results
there are several exercises provided to
the lab Network per year and the results
of each exercise are captured in memos
distributed to senior managers who have
to of course keep an eye on quality
operations of the Laboratories
in this format the recipient
understanding of data is unsurprisingly
disjointed distracted high level case
specific and certainly not memorable
if there's an interesting Trend or
Revelation AKA Waldo hiding in the data
it will almost always be missed
in the early days memos were being
mailed to the recipients as email became
routine way of doing business the memos
started being transmitted as attachments
to emails that hit the rather cluttered
inboxes of the managers at random days
and times of the year
as can be expected mere digitization did
not make the data more accessible nor
noticeable to the managers
via our pilot projects we wanted to
explore a way to look at the data in an
aggregate format
one powerful visual that the user can
interact with to see patterns and Trends
over years
across labs and through different
exercises
for our pilot project we concentrated on
five years of data that represented 100
000 data points in 300 separate reports
this slide shows how the data in PDF
files were transformed into a matrix
format that easily lends itself to
further manipulation and visualization
through various data science tools
this dashboard is interactive for easy
access
transparency relational observation and
Trend analysis
so was there a trend or pattern hiding
in our data that became visible when one
looked at the totality of information in
a structured way was there a Waldo
hiding in our data
there indeed was a Waldo that we
uncovered in our Cowboy data of five
years
Trends in reported findings led to an
investigation that uncovered a practice
used by some Laboratories that caused a
reagent to sit too long on the bench
leading to slight evaporation of the
solvent
which in turn led to slight
overestimation of concentration of the
proficiency samples
the workflow was modified and all the
labs using the defective workflow
attained much tighter standard
deviations on their measurements
in this instance the methodology was
fine but handling during method steps
needed to be modified
so we were indeed able to find the wall
though or at least one of the Waldo's
that was hiding in this busy data
so what are some other applications of r
that we decided to look into so in
addition to systematically looking at
Big Data we also use visualization in R
to assess impacts from our scientific
activities to inform future investment
decisions
data visualization also helps us
understand evolution of our research
landscape Trends from year to year
provide insight into laboratory
principal investigator activity in
research publication frequency
stratification of projects among
different regulated areas
the evolving expertise and proficiency
of our Workforce productivity in our
organization and connectedness and
collaboration of our laboratory Network
since research impact is a hard to
quantify concept we've come up with some
evaluative metrics in order to assess
return on investment from our scientific
activities
this slide shows the buckets of metrics
we use to understand impact and here the
different font sizes represent the
amount of output in each impact bucket
these metrics try to go Beyond near
bibliometrics and try to get at more
nuanced outputs such as whether the
research led to a method that was used
in a coordinated agency response to an
emergency
whether the research stimulated
diversification and modernization of our
technology platform
whether the research increased our
analytical Readiness and preparedness to
Future public health events
this is an example of a court diagram
that we've generated using gar that
packs a lot of information
it shows the relative size of research
activity in the various FDA regulated
areas and how much output each area of
research has produced in our various
impact buckets so at a glance you can
immediately see we're very active in
food related research as opposed to
pharmaceutical and tobacco and devices
where do we want to go next with our
utilization of r
we would like to advance our Mastery of
R to the point that we can start using
clustering and other predictive
relational models for product risk
assessment product profiling
post-market critical quality Factor
monitoring of FDA regulated commodities
being able to leverage such models would
help us optimize our method parameters
based on analyte Matrix scope
perform risk assessment of incoming
import items based on country of origin
package features historically importer
information
and identifying and classify contaminant
profiles in typically consumed Foods
identifying patterns in our existing
databases to inform future decisions
will introduce operational efficiencies
and allow FDA to focus these limited
resources on the products and firms that
pose the largest risk to consumer health
and safety
to recap our strategic goal is to expand
the use of r at FDA or a to Target
products optimize operations and
communicate harvested information
we'd like to build a Workforce that is
proficient in tools such as R so we can
take charge of our data
FDA data forward which was mentioned
earlier is part of the FDA lifelong
learning lifelong learning platform and
teaches basics of art to cohorts of
students who are FDA employees
and um Department of Human Health
Services HHS data collab is another
training activity that just got launched
if day is under Department of Health and
Human and Health Services
and finally we would like to continue
Mining and retaining historical data in
a structured format and expanding our
cumulatively increasing knowledge base
to help with our investment decisions
operational decisions risk assessment
decisions and response to emergency
decisions
and that is the end of our talk ahead of
our time and that's our contact
information and we'd love to answer any
questions you may have during the
breakup thank you for your attention